yeah go for it now you may have seen a
Rubens tube before that's basically a
pipe with a bunch of holes in it and you
pump in a flammable gas and light it on
fire
so you basically create a row of Bunsen
burners what's really cool is to play
some sounds into the tube and you can
actually set up standing waves that is
there are areas there are patterns of
the vibration of the air where there's a
lot of vibration in some parts and not
very much vibration in other parts now
that affects the flow rate of the gas
inside that tube into the atmosphere and
so it affects the height of those flames
so basically you can visualize the
standing wave pattern I'm currently in
Denmark with a team of physics and
chemistry demonstrators who have taken
this experiment to the next level
they've actually created a
two-dimensional Rubens tube a whole
plane of a Bunsen burners effectively
how many holes in this tube and 2500
2500 in this pyro board so we're gonna
see 2500 little flames so do you want to
light it up yes I really want to light
it up
why did you make this because we really
like the Rubens tube but then before
when you put on fire then it always gets
better we can just find us in any way
this is below there
so what are we seeing here it's pretty
much like this anyway
so those frequency that makes a standing
wave in this box so this is like the
fundamental
[Music]
can you show me what happens when you
vary the volume a little bit
hahaha that was awesome okay should we
try to find another standing wave yes
[Music]
before
it's weird with the microphones I can
actually hear like here I'm in a node
and then here
I'm an antinode
here I'm in a no
that's all I can I can hear it like here
is very much antidote
this is an ode and you guys can hear it
it's incredible
the flames must be coming out in the
antinodes the flames are coming up in
the engine oh yeah you can even hear it
yeah that's incredible
that is awesome we just learned
something yeah what happens if we try to
go higher frequency
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah that's a good one
that is crazy we're right in the
antidote
[Music]
she is okay oh my yes i hurting now that
was painful
what are we try to put something more
pleasing to the ear through the speaker
and see what happens I think that's good
yeah let's put some music on there you
ready
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so you go around Denmark showing kids
all about physics we do that's what we
do you show them the pyro board we show
them the power board and we show them a
whole lot of other stuff and you guys
are also on YouTube yep we have a
YouTube channel you can go to it on this
link right here go check it out if you
want to see more of what these guys are
up to
it's awesome it's great ahoy that is the
actual Czech word for hello I have made
it to all emot-- in the Czech Republic
and this is partly thanks to support
from audible.com the leading provider of
audiobooks with over 150,000 titles in
all areas of literature including
fiction nonfiction and periodicals now
today I wanted to recommend a book which
is a little bit European it's called
Galileo's daughter by Dava Sobel I love
this book because it includes the actual
letters written from Galileo's daughter
to him during his life and it really
reveals what he must have gone through
as a human being I mean we all know
about his science and about you know the
trials that he went through but to see
this kind of insight into his personal
life I think is remarkable so you should
really check out this book and you can
download it for free by going to
audible.com/veritasium or you can pick
any other book of your choosing for a
one-month free trial so I really want to
thank audible for supporting me and
allowing me to go and meet great
scientists and filmmakers and lots of
people all around the world also I
should note that I will be hosting
Michio Kaku in Brisbane and Melbourne on
June fifth and six links in the
doobly-doo I would love to see you there
thank you so much for watching and I
will see you somewhere else in the world
bye